learning so this is joint work of my
students Amiata poor bunny he's a
student PhD student of Stanford and a
lot of the work is based on a paper that
we discussed a few weeks ago I CML as
well some where we send follow-ups ok so
there's been a lot of talk about you
know how data is really the fuel or
electricity or whatever analogy you want
to make that drives all the data science
machine learning right and for many
people who actually work on applications
special learning they know that know
getting the right data sets together
it's really probably the most
challenging aspect of getting the
machine learning system to work so
getting the right data sets this really
affects everything that we do here right
so if you are know a machine learning
researcher where analyst for engineers
right so you typically you have data
from different sources from you from
different hospitals with different
patients and they'd have different
qualities right so you want to know what
kind of what kind of data has higher
quality than others what they what it is
more useful to collect so if you're a
shared data vendor which is many of the
companies around here right there have
the business model sort of collecting
data or buying and selling datasets
right so they have the problem of how to
really kind of come up with the right
values the price for the data that
they're buying and selling and probably
more importantly so if you're actually
individual consumer or data producer
which I think all of us here are then
there's very important questions
regulatory questions about how do you
what's the right way and what's the fair
way to compensate individuals for the
data that they generates that data that
they produce this is actually extremely
salient now so it's just a couple weeks
ago at the end of June right there's a
bill in the US Senate which proposes to
two mandates that SCC's to to compute
the value of data for all the companies
was a hundred million consumers or more
i Security's large companies to in order
to not to t be evaluated but as ICC
neotec aashiq quantify the value of the
D consumer D that you're you're
collecting and locally here in
California as the governor of California
Gavin Newsom
it's also proposed policies of data
dividend whereby individual consumers in
California will actually be compensated
by the tech companies by the Google and
Facebook's for the data that they
generates so for all pieces right so the
policies are interesting but there's
also questions of what is what is
actually meaning to fairly compensate
individuals for the data right what is
the value of those data
so that's really the goal of off the top
today to think about what is the right
framework I think about data evaluation
especially in the context of machine
learning right and so that's I think the
sort of core fundamental problem that we
want to address if we want to a tackle
each of these different application
areas and it's awesome I said I think of
this is really an important problem for
both machine learning data science
communities but especially for the
fairness community right so I think
there's a lot of interesting questions
here about what is the the fair way the
equitable ways to actually compensate
what you are to credit individuals for
the value of their data and despite I
think being a quite a foundation or
important problem there's actually
relatively little work done on this in
the product community so I'll talk about
some recent works but actually I think
there's a lot of room for new works
which I'm hoping to discuss here ok so
if you make this a little bit more
concrete all right so specifically we're
interested in the value of data in the
context of machine learning right so
more more and supervised machine
learning mostly I'll talk about for this
talk so here the idea is that so you
have some training data that's used to
train some particular predictor right if
you want to predict for breast cancer I
want to predict for diabetes right you
collect data to Train predictor for that
task the data here can come from
different sources right this could be
different hospitals different
individuals or different data vendors
you can have different qualities your
predictor is going to achieve some
performance right some accuracy or f1
score your favorite metric right for
that task that you're interested in the
goal here is how do we actually say
that's which data points is responsible
or deserves credit for the mistakes or
for the good performance that is
predictor achieves
okay so a little bit more concretely so
that the setting they're working was
here we'll have three main ingredients
right this is common ingredients for
supervised machine learning so we start
with some data sets you can think of
each individual points yours being data
from a particular individual or from a
particular source right so each data
point actually could be itself a subset
of data so you have a particular
learning algorithm this could be your
favorite deep learning algorithm or SVM
right that takes the data and learns a
predictor and you tell me what is your
favorite performance evaluation metric
which it could be accuracy f1 score
right your favorite metric when you have
these three ingredients right so we let
say if your algorithm trainer's dataset
achieves accuracy of point eight so the
problem of data evaluation that we
talked about here is that you want to
actually allocate that point eight to
each of your three data points or three
data sources
all right so just a couple of remarks
here so here the value of a particular
data point here depends on all three
ingredients of my machine learning
pipeline right it depends on who else is
in my training data sets depends on the
learning algorithm itself and it also
depends on your specific tasks and
performance metric okay you use a
different metric or even tradition tasks
your value could differ right so there
are many possible ways to think about
how to split up the performance value
amount of training data points right so
a very common one is basically this
approach let's called leave one out
method so I'll just briefly describe it
here and this is probably the most
widely used or maybe the most intuitive
version of how do they modify the value
of theta
alright so suppose I have these three
data points I train a model on this I'm
interested in thinking about what is the
value of this star here so the simplest
approach intuitively is I just simply
leave the star out right remove it from
my training data now I'll have the other
two data points I trained fit in through
my learning algorithm right maybe I will
learn a different classification
boundary decision boundary and the chips
and I see what is the performance of a
learning algorithm when this data point
is no longer present so the change in
the performance of the of the learning
algorithm when the data point is present
or absent
so that's my Tivo and out score for that
data point and I can do this in
principle for every data point in my
training set
so this is actually a very widely used
statistic in statistics and machine
learning and there are many variations
and approaches to approximate this even
out score all right so recently there's
been a lot of work very nice working
machine learning on computing leverage
cores the influence function is the
influence words which are all
essentially approximations to this level
and outscore so this is one you know one
approach to capture the value of theta
and the question here is this you know
does this leave one out score where oh
for prevision the set actually captured
the importance of individual data
sources to individual data points all
right so what are the properties and
they're to satisfy some desirable
properties so I'll discuss today is that
this standard cannot leave one out score
actually has posed quite a lot of
theoretical and empirical limitations
when we actually want to apply it to
quantify the value of data in machine
learning
and you know so I said no alternative
further spin some several recent works
basically proposing this concept of data
Shapley value as an alternative to
compute the value of theta so this is
actually a series of for sum of parallel
papers including our paper a couple of
weeks over from ICML and a couple of
other nice papers presented recently
that you explore the idea of data
Shapley value so to motivate the Shapley
value I want to first tell you about
what are some general principles let's
say desirable properties that would like
any data valuation scheme to satisfy
that's it we on these principles then we
can naturally lead to you what is needed
shatavari is so the first property
that's no maybe we all care about is
that okay so if you have data what
you'll be the point all right if I add
that data point to any other subset of
my training data and by adding that it
never changed the performance of my
training data right then the data point
do does nothing for my training
algorithm and I should assign zero value
and you should ask me questions if you
have complaints about any of these yes
so that the subset of the rest of the
day you take the null set then any data
point will always have value right not
necessarily right I mean I could have so
improper have data points I just really
has nothing to my learning algorithm has
no information content so here I'm
saying that in principle if this is if
it never changes the performance then I
should assign it zero value
okay so the second property is that we
have two data points right if adding
that either point to any sub subset of
my data also keeps the same performance
then basically by symmetry I should
assign the same value and the third one
I think it's easier to explain the
context of machine learning right so
it's this become postable property which
says so so a machine learning is
supervised learning right so you're
typically your performance is defined as
on some test data set which is usually a
psalm over the performance on individual
test points right if you're looking at
accuracy then you look at average
accuracy across it's a bunch of
independent test points then the idea
here is that if I add or remove a
particular test point from my evaluation
metric right I should simply be adding
or removing the value of each training
data point for that test point
okay yes should I think of the value
function just taking the individual data
point or should I also think think about
it as a function that might fall to
individual data point and also the
existing data you already have right
Jeff cheery little one yeah so the the
the actual value function is actually
going to depend on all three ingredients
right it depends on who is might it like
my entire data set all the points in it
the particle rule learning algorithm and
my performance metric depends on all
three years
okay so if we agree that these three
properties are reasonable then then
there's surfa is actually only one way
to value data that satisfy these
properties
it's given by this formula let me just
parse it for you so the value of
particular data point K right so here's
what we do to compute it so you look at
all the possible subsets of your data we
extend this not contain its point K
right so you see okay so how much does
the performance change if I add K to
that subset alright so this this is
basically the marginal change in
performance by adding the point K and I
do some normalization by dividing by the
number of sets that have size K I just
some some weighting scheme normalization
it turns out that this is basically the
the only way you can value data if you
want to satisfy these desirable
properties alright so the intuition of
this is that this is really computing
the expected contribution of adding this
data points where the expectation is
over all the possible sets so the
difference from leave one out scores
that to leave one out is only looking at
the marginal contribution of adding data
points to the rest of the data right to
the N minus one other data points so the
Shapley value is actually computing that
barge the contribution averaged over all
possible sets right from the both small
data sets right one or five data points
to two larger subsets of your data so
it's looking at across this whole
resolution which potentially gives it
higher more information content okay so
here's the illustration of how we
actually compute Shapley value for the
same example so first what we do is that
we look at the first steps the same as
the leave one out score but now we have
to look at other subsets alright so if
I'm looking at the start point right so
I look at its marginal contribution when
I add it to the red points or when I add
it to the other blue point and I also
add compute how much it adds if it's the
point by itself so these are all the
possible marginal contributions of this
star and I add all of that together with
some appropriate weighting and I get the
score of 0.05
okay at every step in the learning
algorithm that's right so I'll tell you
so a lot of our work is on developing
efficient algorithms to estimate this
chap devalue so I'll tell you in the
bits about how do we actually estimate
this right this is yeah so if you want
to compute it exactly then you have to
compute it every step if your learning
algorithm you said you could actually
group some data together called the set
one data point right yes so what's the
relation between the Shapley value of
the if you break up this and the
individual points in the set versus the
Shapley value of the set itself as one
is one point good question so in general
there's not a clear relationship between
the Shafi value of the individual data
points and the sets right so here we
often use sets if we want to first just
make it computationally more tractable
first we just group individuals that are
from the movie from the same hospital
together to say what is the value of the
updater from that Hospital I shall show
you some examples of that
okay so the credit of the Shafi value
really goes back to two economists right
so it's actually being well study in
economics this idea of Shapley values so
the setting their sets now if everyone
in this room we all work together to
solve some task and we get a bonus all
right how do we actually split up that
bonus around everyone in this room so
everyone you know it's fairly
compensated right so that's the core of
a core idea from cropped up game theory
so the variation here is that instead of
having individuals right so individual
brings their own data for everyone's
data then work together to achieve some
task which in this case would be
training this machine learning algorithm
and the outputs are achieved some
performance which we didn't want to
allocate back to the individual data
points so that's the analogy to the
Shafi value okay so here's the agenda
for the rest of the talk so I want to
first tell you now we introduced these
two ideas of data valuation right the
Shapley value and leave one out scores
so how do they actually compare across
various empirical performance empirical
data sets the second part is actually
now that we have the Shapley value can
we actually apply it to improve somehow
these fairness tasks that we care about
and lastly are the requests about how to
efficiently estimate a free value and
other statistical properties that we
might care about yes yeah so I was top
it a bit more here so so right now the
Shafi value
no so it's a well-defined concept right
so gives you a value for every training
data points right on the sum of the
value for the training data points will
equal to the final performance that I
care about so my first year is just a
final performance metric right maybe my
accuracy right and I'm going to alqaeda
accuracy entirely among each of my
training data points that they sum up to
the to the final performance
so like the Lee point out value the
Shapley value can be negative correct
so am i right in thinking that typically
a point that the classifier gets wrong
will confuse the training algorithm if
it tries to get it right and thus will
slightly decrease that you know decrease
the accuracy and that's well it seems
like there's a lot of settings where the
data that the classifier gets wrong are
actually really really useful yes in
particular it might stimulate you to go
to a better class of classifiers and
recognize that there was something
systematic that you were getting wrong
so the idea that it's wrong of negative
values I don't know so let me actually
show you some examples of that right of
where the negative values come from but
that's a great point okay so so I think
we're all excited to apply this concept
right so we applied it to actually a
bunch of data virtual real data sets so
this is actually the UK power packs it's
actually one of the most valuable large
data sets in the biomedical community
right so it's about half a million
people we have the genetics medical
records from each of these individuals
from the UK right so the data notice a
huge international effort there are many
many academic groups and companies using
this data sets so here we just compute a
Shapley value for the data set all right
so the data is actually collected from
these 22 locations in the UK right so
the bar here indicates how many
individuals here are participants from
each of those locations if you're
looking at a particular prediction task
which is a sort of a common task of
predicting lung cancer diagnosis going
forward is your risk for lung cancer
right here we're going to compute a
Shapley value for each of those
locations right for each of the center's
and we do find exactly the setting that
you mentioned right so it is possible
that you have locations where the actual
the Shapley value for that location is
negative in particular for Nottingham so
you have to actually have quite negative
Shafi values which means that's
intuitively that it's actually the data
from Nottingham
is actually skewing the predictive model
in a way that's detrimental to its
overall performance okay so now the
question is so it does certain vital
follow-up is what is happening in
Nottingham right so what's going on
there and keep Kim that give us
additional insights and so what we dig
deeper into this so it turns out that
actually the data quality at Nottingham
is just as good as the data from other
places right gonna be the first mode
first reason you might think for data
here be negative maybe the the
measurement quality is worse right but
it's actually as good as the data from
other applications so it turns out
that's the demographic relations
demographic profile in Nottingham for
people that develop lung cancer is
actually quite different from other
parts of the UK so we don't really know
the causal mechanisms right but all that
we observe is that the demographic
profile is actually quite different but
it certainly invites hypotheses about
the mechanisms right so what that means
is that's actually not data from
Nottingham it is good quality data but
it's actually essentially shifting the
distribution in a way that's hurts the
performance that's why it has the
negative value right so the quality here
so to compute the Shapley value or the
quality of data so we basically so there
the first way for collecting genomics
data all right so there are particular
metrics to see how good is your
sequencing machines where are the
particular batch effects in those data
so we don't think there's issues there
with that metric has to choose what the
tech data is going to be in some sense
so if you chose the test here that'd be
all from Nottingham as well you might
have got good question yeah so so here
we're using the standard test metric
which is which usually is designed for
the whole country
right so it's here you have you have one
lung cancer predicting your who's on the
supply to the whole country
and we're seeing okay so if you include
Nottingham's data in the training set
there that's actually hurting that
national predictor
and we did it for other diseases to
colon cancer as well okay
so let's actually dive a little bit
deeper into what are these negative
values and what do they what do they
actually mean all right so the first
thing you want want to care about is
okay so if you take individuals so
remember we have the Shapley value for
the center that I showed you before but
also have the Shafi value for the
individual participants as if you take
individual to have negative Shapley
value and just simply remove them from
your training data all right what is
that actually what is that how does that
actually change the performance of the
algorithm so just as a baseline
comparison let's say if you just
randomly select individuals remove them
from your training data where your
Trinity is getting smaller and the
algorithms performance is you know it's
getting worse and sure it's basically
you take the negative leave one out
individuals all right so you remove
those from your data sets right so the
so the algorithm performance is also
getting worse right but if you actually
remove individuals negative Shapley
value you actually see something that's
very different which is actually the
performance of the algorithm improves
right as you removing this individuals
so are the evaluations of the Shapley
value on like a validation set that says
yes we have two test sets ones for
computing Shapley value and ones for
evaluating performance
and as the chef said evenly distributed
across these locations or proportional
to the that's right so it's a it's a
representative national sample test a
size that's not changed when you take
out yes the test doesn't change right
here we're just taking our data points
from the training sets yes this is for
the same I believe for the same cancer
prediction tasks okay so the flip side
of this is that okay so instead of
removing negative ba in different
individuals that's ads individuals that
have high Shapley value how does that
change the performance the algorithm
again for comparison we just add random
individuals the red line here we're
adding the picture society without score
alright so they actually basically do
the same thing but adding individuals
high sharply value actually really
improves the positive caffeine really
improves the performance
so we find that actually for many
settings that you run out it's doing
essentially the same as random right
because these datasets are so large
they're quite noisy so here I don't know
why you know why it's actually doing
worse than random for individuals but we
certainly don't find it to do you know
any significant random right right so
that's course I think going is tradition
birds
what is so now remember one for the
ingredients for computing Shafi value is
the perform performance metric right so
here the performance metric is a
standard one which is the national
performance on the wind over the entire
UK alright so certainly I think if we
design more fine-grained performance
metrics then we'll see different
phenomenon all right so here we're just
saying ok so let's take the standard
ones that people use right how does such
Lehrer moving if that's the metric that
you care about which is what people do
right how does actually removing the
negative individuals affect that metric
I think certainly certainly it raises
the question of maybe that national
metrics are not the best ones to use so
let me actually go a little bit more so
maybe people can take up some more
questions in the next steps okay
so this is also a more closer
investigation into the native shuttle
values or so turns out that's in some
data sets right so the negative values
actually come from data points that are
just mislabeled all right so we had a
particulars of noisy label data set and
we'll just look at the individual data
points that have negative Shapley value
and I just double check them to see are
those actually correctly labeled or not
right we can just manually check them
again and again for comparison we just
take random data points or our data
points that have the smallest leave one
out scores so the y axis here
corresponds to how many mislabel data
points do I discover by checking these
points that have the smallest response
values if I do the value based on
randomly or leave one out I know there's
very little difference in terms of how
how much they're discovering how often
they discover the bad data points but if
you actually check the data points to
have negative Shafi values you see very
clearly that no it's really detect
detecting data points that are
mislabeled right so that's sort of a
also a case where you can have negative
Shapley values
okay so I think so the first part is to
show that you know empirically oh yes
the scraps you've been showing us you
fix the data set and you fix the
performance metric but I imagine you
could get different cracks of use
different learning algorithms yes yeah
so so we we try a variety of learning
algorithms ranging from convolutional
neural networks to logistic regression
so then both small and large so the
results are they do depend on the
learning algorithm but the overall trend
is very robust
right so the leave the leave one out
always performs similar to random and
then Shapley tends to do is
substantially better than both so in the
in appendix of paper we show the results
for a lot of the trends with learning
algorithm through some theorems like
sadly for learning algorithms in this
class yeah yeah so that's a great open
question where we have some ideas how to
do that but not nothing concrete yet but
you're happy to chat more about that
later okay so the first part is just to
show you okay so both theoretically
empirically right so the commonly used
lead went out scores actually really
does not capture information value of
theta as well as the Shapley scores the
second part I want to show you is
actually how do we use the Shapley
scores to really solve some of the
furnace questions that arise from
transferring machine learning models
across different populations
here's a standard kind of a setting
right so you have image recognition and
this is I think sort of a problem that
many of you have have worked on or have
thought about is you have your training
data which really takes sort of a
standard benchmark training data sets
the data sets where training is actually
quite imbalanced right so you have a lot
more let's say white males so here I'm
showing you a random samples from the
training data so if you actually deploy
the algorithm in application right you
see a lot more diverse individuals
that's differ from your training dataset
that's why the performance drops
especially for minority applications we
can do now is that we actually have a
Shapley value right for each of my
training data points so let's say if I
have a small you know curated test data
set that come from more diverse
individuals I actually have a value
right positive or negative for each of
my training data points so the simplest
idea is what if I just simply reweighed
my training data point by its chaplet
value or the intuition being that data
points that actually are more useful
right for diverse populations would have
higher Shafi value on giving it higher
values would improve the algorithm so
here's basically we just know a random
sample of the highly valued images right
from my training set and you can see
that they actually capture a lot more
diverse individuals and those are a lot
more women and it's just doing this
simple idea of simply be waiting with
each of my training points by the
Shapley value we train the same
composition network right
on this data set actually immediately
leads to quite substantial improvements
in performance on a down on deployment
and here you're fixing your test data
set and asking when by real waiting are
you improving the transportation of that
particular test it isn't what guarantees
okay
yeah yes so I think this really richest
question so here we're actually quite
careful right so we split a test dataset
into two verse you have a small test
dataset that's just used to compute a
Shapley value and to do that we actually
just only need a few hundred examples
and then to actually evaluate the
performance we do it on this how the
test data sets which is much larger and
independent from what's used to a
computer Shafi values so that's supposed
to actually simulate the realistic
settings when we go I have a small
curated data sets small but no well
labeled that I can use to complete the
Shapley values but then when I actually
do deployment have a lot more unlabeled
data points
so another application of this and quite
interesting is in medical settings right
so many of the algorithms suddenly seen
the news about achieving their doctor or
dermatologist level performance they're
actually trained by quite heterogeneous
datasets great from the Google image and
so on right so if you take one of these
Yahoo's ohms or the Trinity set the
random samples you can have you know if
you just go on Google Images search for
the different dermatology conditions you
get all sorts of very heterogeneous lots
of junk in the training dataset the
clinical examples that you actually care
about the application are look quite
different right and we typically have a
small number of clinically labeled test
examples so again we can do the same
idea right just simply reweighed each of
our training points by the Shapley value
right so the high D value ones tens to
pick out images some strands that are
more more informative less noisy and
simply do the integrated training as she
immediately improves the performance
quite a bit sir but by double-digits on
my clinical settings so we tried this
idea these are two examples on variety
of other examples from images to natural
language processing or in NLP you can
also have these similar settings where
it seems to be quite consistent that
we're waiting by Shapley value these two
substantial performance my deploy
examples I might deploy deployment
studies there certainly I think there
are limitations to how much you can push
this approach but I think this is sort
of a general approach to potentially
make some of the machine learning models
more transferable and improve the
fairness and equity okay so you
remaining few minutes I want to quickly
go over some of the other questions that
we had discussed there and leave some
more room for for discussion so the
first point is that okay so how do we
actually compute Shapley value
especially when you have a large neural
network a large model so so there's a
lot of things on here but let me just
explain the intuition so intuition is
that remember to compute the Shapley
value you're essentially looking at how
much this adding this data point
contributes to different subsets of
other data points in my training set
so that's actually in some way not so
different from how what you're already
doing we were computing gradient descent
over your entire training set right if
you do SVD you're just taking the tail
one pass over your 20 data sets so what
we're doing here is basically to compute
the estimation value intuitively we just
look at multiple epochs each epoch we
have a random permutation of all of my
training points and I keep track of at
every gradient step how much did each
batch where each individual training
points the gradient for that points how
much did that actually improve the
algorithm right so that's actually my
estimate for the marginal contribution
of adding a data point to my previous
set so that time for computing this is
essentially the same time as takes me to
train the original component to Train
the original deep learning model so this
does not give you an exact Shapley value
but if you actually imagine doing this
sort of in parallel over several
different multicolored iterations of the
permutations of your training points it
actually gets better Monte Carlo
estimates for the shop evaluate data
points
so that's actually how we estimate
Shapley value on these large large ml
models so a couple of other questions
that people I think related questions
that people brought up here right so
first is that so you know in the game
theory context everything is given right
the players are given but in context of
data science in machine learning where
data is actually sample from
distributions so then it's natural to
ask about okay so what are the
statistical properties of this Chaffey
value which itself is now a random
variable right it depends on the
underlying data distribution I think
that's actually a very wide open area
there's very little known about this
this is called property that that's
something that that we been working on
we're starting to work on so the second
point is that typically two right now to
compute the Shapley value we actually
require that we have access to the whole
data set right so the entire training
data sets so typically let's say if
you're you know if you're a company
looking at data sets from different
potential different vendors you don't
actually have access to the entire data
set from the each of the vendors and we
you only have access to a small subset
of the data sets so there's a
interesting question about how do you
actually officially extrapolate Shapley
values from small subsets of data and
then this point I think is also brought
up into more of the earlier questions so
there's these three properties I listed
for the Shapley value but I think
they're not always appropriate in a
certain data science context alright so
for example the Shapley value as we seen
can be negative but in many contexts you
know we can't really charge people money
for the data that they generate but even
if it ends up being internally or
negative data right so often you the
best you can do is to say okay so you
know if your data ends up having
negative Shaklee value which is science
Eero of value or some baseline value so
that turns out actually already breaks
the formulations of Shapley value right
so you can actually you cannot you know
it's not as so if you actually threshold
the negative values to be zero right so
that actually breaks a lot of other
vaccines and property values so how do
you
the you know how the pocket design
valuation schemes that are robust to
that and the current scheme of Shafi
value is also vulnerable to certain
manipulations attacks right so for
example you have individuals know that
say if they many they can manipulate
their data in a way to extract higher
values from the from the algorithm I
think these are all some open areas that
requires more investigation so so we
think of the Shapley value is sort of
you know a first step towards really
thinking about more systematic ways to
quantify the value of data in the
context of machine learning I mean I
think it's gonna be extremely
fundamental important question given all
the regulations about data valuation and
how to you know how to charge companies
for the value of these data in addition
to sort of these regulatory questions
seeing that this I think the data Shafi
value is actually quite useful for some
core ml tasks such as thick domain
adaptation and so on and here as we said
so the value depends on the task but you
have to be very careful increasing what
task you are evaluating towards so this
is not really getting at the point of
what is the intrinsic value of data
all right so we're not trying to say
this data has some intrinsic value sure
the ball you only make sense respect to
a specific task and that may be a
limitation to the approach as well so we
have the other software and paper
available for computing estimating
Shapley values some happy to to take
some more questions humans
later
and more question this
what sort of caveat should be attached
to this as well like fairness yes I
guess we there's the place that we can
say this improves an algorithm about Tom
I guess my fear is that if we have some
notion of fairness or equitability in
how we define something then startup or
a big company and just say okay if I
catch this to it then I can calm I think
there but like if we're predicting
recidivism rates or something can
improving and I'll just say if the
algorithm is pretty predicting how
racist our society is would improve
being an algorithm just say it predicts
the racist society better but people
that use recidivism this is just
reflecting how society is and we need to
be just as racist as it's telling us so
like is there caveats where
I guess if we're talking where it works
with how can we talk about where it
wouldn't work as well yes I think
certain important questions to consider
so the this current studying a patina
Shapley value is really developed around
the idea of how do we value data that's
already in place right algorithms have
already been trained on loss data how do
we actually assign baggage there and
that's as we said is motivated by the
current policy and regulatory questions
where we actually need to value come up
with values for those kinds of data the
existing algorithms so I think going
forward may be one interesting
application of Shapley values think
about what are ways to collect better
data right because if you really want to
maybe fundamentally improve the
performance your models you certainly
need especially across more diverse
population see they actually need to
collect better data sets and we've seen
that one application acceptable omission
briefly is when you actually you know if
you just take individuals with high
Shapley value right and that didn't see
what it is that actually helps the model
a lot more than its adding other
settings right so it's now becoming
closer to like an active learning kinds
of study and I think that's one
interesting places where you can think
about you know if we know which kinds of
data is more valuable and we actually
put more resources allocations to
collect more data from those populations
I guess my question is not that
the data is bad or it's incorrect that
the data is good but it's reflecting
bad biases we already have so that is
chef Laval you would actually do well in
saying I actually yeah the prediction
thing would be predict actually it's
even more racist than we previously
thought
but um right in that case I would say it
still might be useful to use chappy
value as a diagnostic tool right now you
see okay so what are the 20 data points
that are leading to potentially damaging
predictions yes I mean so many of these
questions that have been asked could be
addressed if there could be a Shapley
value definition for a metric that's not
a scalar but a vector so for example if
you have a minim Ettrick that takes into
account fairness to you know accuracy on
different populations or something like
that or they're just one value it's a
vector of values then there any hope of
defining a Shapley value for vector
output matrix
idea i mean so the current approach is
usually people you have multiple
objectives those are added together with
no some hyper parameter into one triple
Lagrangian term once you have that then
you can compute up a values for it but
if you actually really have some you
know honest vector of objectives then we
don't know how to extend this right now
two questions well what is the question
time questions when you mention the
manipul ability is faculty values
what were you assuming you can validate
like what what parts of a data point
that I have of someone can I verify that
they have manipulated or not manipulated
because that conceivably matters a lot
and then the other comment I would make
is while computer scientists do a lot of
work and generally call everything like
worst case economists do do things in
the distributional sense so you should
probably if you're talking to a calmness
like big things like chef we values
early find it
yeah it's the manipulation I think
that's a wide-open area so currently to
in order to compute a Shappy value we're
essentially working in a somewhat
constrained setting where I imagine I
have the algorithm and I already have
off the training data set together
I collected now I'm just computing these
values
my question or they like adding yeah so
potentially people could for example you
know adds additional or modify the
features in the data set they could even
do things like maybe create multiple
fake accounts right it's just duplicated
data K times and create a fake accounts
to extract upon more more more more
revenue so those are all possible
manipulation yeah it's just for UK one
cancer example did your classifier take
in the location to data point came from
a Zico Gary yes so so I remember the
stuff classifier would have there's
demographics the location is awesome
various biomarkers and lifestyle
information data point came from
Nottingham did not account points are
still doing words yeah that's right
yeah Mesa so there could be quite
complicated interactions that's a nice
and curious yeah
okay thank you
[Applause]